[Music]
all right we showed you last night
appalling conditions in the Democratic
run city of Baltimore tonight we want to
tell you about another liberal city
pretty much destroyed
I don't like San Francisco right near
Nancy Pelosi's house in Los Angeles 2020
Democratic hopefuls they're there in
Detroit this week yes trying to win
their party's nomination to impose the
green New Deal disaster but what they
probably won't talk about are the
liberal policy failures that took place
in the Motor City now going on decades
according to the most recent data
available Detroit has the worst
unemployment rate of any major US city a
whopping eight point eight percent it
has the worst poverty rate thirty seven
point nine percent and it is the second
highest murder rate only behind
Baltimore and the worst violent crime
rate as well we sent our own Lawrence
Jones are traveling correspondent to
Detroit to see what the people who live
there have to say about the way their
city is being run take a look so the
leaders here you think they representing
the community effectively warden you
don't know who the leaders are no you
never see them coming around you know
it's hard when it comes up campaign time
to select someone you know everybody's
talking a good game but nobody's doing
nothing elected officials that promise
all this change are they delivering not
to me I don't see it tell me about the
crime Oh
five people shot last night here a lot
of crime behind me homicide right behind
this yeah shooting always back yeah my
kids say y'all hear the gunfire and
jumped on the floor and that's where
they slept it would be fuel to get back
in the bed because they're gonna fire
back there tell me about the housing
situation
oh the housing is bad it's like slumlord
so I used to many with the housing going
down they need to build more rec centers
bring some Oh rec centers to give the
young kids something to do in the
neighborhoods it wouldn't be so much
crime around the area so you getting out
of here yeah why it's time to go
nothing's here nothing's here I feel bad
I want to go I've been here six to six
years and I want
go you ready to leave look at this mess
alright joining us now is Hannity
special correspondent investigative
reporter and also editor-in-chief campus
for former own Lawrence Jones also with
us the CEO of the national diversity
Coalition for Trump that would be pastor
Daryl Scott
I actually preached from the pulpit of
his church who's the worst hour you've
ever heard but I did it I tried my best
Lawrence let me start with you I'm
watching the people in Baltimore I'm
watching your reports in San Francisco
LA you've been to Baltimore now you're
in Detroit those are our fellow citizens
they're suffering and they deserve
better the question is why are the same
liberal politicians elected every cycle
why that's a good question son and I
don't know if it's because people aren't
showing up to the polls but it's a
depressing state here you know I went to
Detroit with my producer without the
camera crew we come back an hour later
and it's a crime scene a homicide
happened within an hour of going to one
location looking and surveying it it was
already a crime scene when mothers have
to tell their kids to sleep on the floor
can you imagine that that for the
audience out there telling your kids
they belong in their bed they should
feel safe that they have to sleep on the
floor so they don't get gunfire that is
a tragedy and I like I said last night
there has to be an opening for
conservatives and Republicans to go in
these communities I don't think these
people care about party at this point
they just want someone to fix the pain
you know pastor Scott I got to know you
I your your look like a pastor in the
streets and and I know because you've
asked me to help whenever I could not my
answer is always yes because I love what
you're doing you're helping you're
helping our fellow citizens out you took
a lot of crap voting for Donald Trump
supporting Donald Trump a lot by the way
anyone who's friends with Donald Trump
gets you know a fair share of heat but
it was you know but we have record low
unemployment right now for
african-americans the best employment
situation since 1969 record no record
low unemployment
Hispanic Americans Asian Americans women
in the workplace that doesn't sound to
me like a racist president that doesn't
care about people of other races that
sounds to me like a problem solver who's
willing to call out a problem for what
it is and I think Donald Trump did the
best thing that Baltimore has ever seen
because now we know how bad they run
this place you're absolutely right
back in 2011 Donald Trump told me that
he believed unemployment underemployment
depressed living conditions contributed
to a lot of the crime and the disparity
that existed in the black community and
that if he became president now he said
this eight years ago that he would do
what he could to address those problems
and he's doing it but urban blight is a
reality throughout America the
politicians show up every two to four
years they walk through the hood they
shake their head they promise to come
back but win or lose they don't come
back and what Donald Trump has done he's
caused America to examine to address to
acknowledge that this this blight this
these depressed conditions exist in
America and that there has to be
something done about it and that's the
reason why we formed the urban
revitalization coalition so that we can
address urban black and revitalize these
neighborhoods absolutely
Lawrence great job special correspondent
investigative reporter pastor you need
to keep us all in your prayers